and then we have uh what's the next one
realize price if you want to talk
through uh realize price
sure so yeah so that was that was from a
momentum standpoint see that it's about
47k when we move on now to the value
framework uh we're talking about you
know like extreme value like cyclical
bottom type of areas for BTC uh we
currently see that as about 22 to 24K
again not necessarily saying that that
is most definitely going to happen just
saying that if you know you got to speak
in if then if then format right so if we
got to that area I would be looking at
you know that's where I'd be you know
betting the farm and you know deploying
all of my dry powder uh just because
it's so plus easy to deploy historically
at some of these levels we're about to
talk about so yeah first we'll start
with realized price uh this currently
sits at twenty four thousand uh USD
that's essentially the you know we talk
about short-term holder cost basis but
realize price is just the absolute
aggregated cost basis uh of all the
utxos on chain uh and so whenever
whenever price goes blow that
historically and served as an amazing
buy opportunity for people with kind of
a multi-year time Horizon and by
definition whatever price is below
realize price what that's telling you is
that you know all in aggregate Market
participants are underwater right
because by definition you're below their
cost basis
um and so that's where you can start to
see some major capitulation Etc uh
that's kind of where you want to be
allocating historically gotcha and then
I know uh our friend z-score is back so
talk to me through what you're seeing
here
yeah I love this chart I think it's um
one of the one of the best ones to be
looking at for for what we're talking
about here from from a value perspective
so this is comparing it's another way to
look at the chart we just looked at but
instead you're just taking a ratio of
price to realize price so whenever again
whenever market price gets below realize
price by definition uh Market
participants are underwater in Aggregate
and so that's when you get into that
green zone at the bottom so if bitcoin's
price was to go below that realized
price around 24 000 then that oscillator
would move down into that green zone the
green zone historically is marked
basically generational buy opportunities
for BTC um so again that's an area where
if we entered that green zone that's for
for me personally of course not
Financial advice uh where I'd be just
looking to deploy all of the remaining
cash that I'm sitting on
um in case you know we you know in case
we we do enter that threshold um
24 000.
yep uh at 24 000. and so you know that
that would be to that would be to start
going into that green zoned uh you know
if we started going below essentially I
have bids ladder down from about 24 to
22k uh and the 22k comes from the next
chart we're looking at uh I'm sorry that
in a few charts and a few charts we're
looking at uh the 200 week the 200 week
moving average has basically caught
every cyclical bottom basically to the
tick
um that's a pretty widely known moving
average that
um is used in almost all markets but for
BTC is has been a great uh signal and so
I have I have my bits ladder down from
that realized price down to that 200
week moving average hey you if you like
this video great we make